من قريه صغيره في الريف الفرنسي بدا
فرانسوا بينوم مسيره امتدت لاكثر من 50
عاما لبناء امبراطوريه كبرى في تجاره
التجزئه والسلع الفاخره وجمع ثروه تقدر
بنحو 39 مليارا و300 مليون دولار جعلته
احد اكثر رجال ثراء ليس في فرنسا فقط بل
وفي العالم كله فما سر هذه الثروه ولد
فرانسوابينو عام
1936 في غرب فرنسا ونشا بينو في الريف
الفرنسي حيث كانت لدى والده شريكه لتجاره
الاخشاب وكذلك بدا هو حياته المهنيه في
ذات المجال حيث ترك المدرسه وهو في
السادسه عشره بعد ان تعرض للتنمر من
زملائه بسبب خلفيته الريفيه في عام
1956 التحق بالجيش لمده عامين
بعدها لمتابعه عمله مع العائله لكن وفاه
والده في عام
1959 جعلته يقدم على خطوات اكبر حيث باع
شركه العائله واصبح مديرا لشركه جوتيفريز
وهي شريكه للاخشاب مقرها في عام
1960 تزوج فرانسوا من الويزات جوت التي
كان لوالدها شركه لتجاره الاخشاب فحصل على
دعم من والد زوجته الذي نقل الشركه اليه
في عام
1962 طور فرانسوا عمل الشركه ووسع نشاطها
من خلال التعامل مع وسطاء في تجاره
الاخشاب شمال اوروبا كما غير اسمها
الىؤسس من خلالها شركته الخاصه لكنه باعها
بعد عده سنوات لشركه بريطانيه وربح نحو
100 مليون فرانك وهو المبلغ الذي استخدمه
للاستحواذ على شركه بينو اس التي كانت على
وشك الافلاس بعد عده اشهر انهارت اسعار
الاخشاب فقام فرانسوا بشراء معظم شركات
منافسيه وفي عام
1988 ادرج الشركه في بورصه باريس لكنها
تخلت عن تجاره الاخشاب ووسعت نطاق اعمالها
لتجاره التجزئه العامه لم تتوقف طموحات
فرانسوا عند سلعه معينه فاشترى حصصا كبيره
في شركات مثل تجاره المفروشات والمتاجر
الكبرى والكتب وتجاره الالكترونيات
بالتجزئه وغيرها الكثير ثم غير اسم الشركه
في عام
1993 لتصبح
التحول الاخر الذي قام به فرانسوا كان
اقتحام تجاره صناعه الرفاهيه حيث اشترى
حصصا ايضا بشركات تعنى بالموضه والزينه
مثل غوتشي وابسانورا وبوشرون وبيت الازياء
البريطاني
اصبحت مجموعه بينو تضم اربعه اقسام
تشغيليه وهي البيع بالتجزئه والبيع
بالجمله والخدمات الماليه والتجاره
الدوليه وباتت لديها شركات تابعه في غرب
افريقيا والبرتغال وتركيا وكوريا وتايلاند
والصين وما لا يقل عن 20 دوله اخرى حول
العالم في عام 2003 سلم بينو اداره شركاته
الى ابنه فرانسواه الذي واصل السير على
خطى والده وعزز اعمال الشركه كما اعاد
تسميتها مره اخرى ليصبح اسمها كيرينج في
عام 2013
يتابع بينو اعمال الشركه وهو الرئيس
الفخري للمجموعه التي تمتلك العلامات
التجاريه الفاخره بلنسيا وبوتيجا فينيتا
وجوتشي والكسندر ام كاكوين وافسان
الى جانب اعماله التجاريه يمتلك بينو
وعائلته
للمزادات الشهيره بالاضافه الى مجموعه
فنيه من 3000 قطعه مع اعمال لبيكاسو
وموندرين وكونز ويعد من الشخصيات المهمه
التي ترعى الفنون في بلده
ليس ذلك الفتى الذي انتقده زملائه يوما
ولم يعد بامكان احد ان يتنمر على خلفيته
الريفيه بعد ان ساعدته في امتلاك ثروه
تقدر بنحو 39 مليارا و300 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]